大家好，最近怎么样？太好了。欢迎来到《未来是低技术：来自 2000 年代初的经验》。举个手，在座有谁真正体验过 2000 年代初的科技？太棒了。那有谁体验过这种东西？
快进到今天，技术变得越来越令人惊叹。这本来应该让人兴奋，但用户体验却在不断变差。原因是，技术在一件特定事情上变得非常非常擅长：把我们困在里面。而在 2000 年代初，互联网是一个你会去访问的地方。你要走到家里的电脑前，等它开机，看看你的 Neopets。
然后你会把它关掉，回到自己的生活里。但 2000 年代初的技术并不是因为设计师更有伦理感、更深思熟虑，所以才更好。它更好，是因为当时设计师还没有拿到那种奖励“困住用户”的商业模式。
到了那个十年末，广告变成了科技公司赚钱的主要方式。于是它们开始优化用户停留在平台上的时间。当商业模式改变，设计也随之改变。我们从为用户设计体验，变成设计参与机制，用用户自己的神经系统来对付他们。那么这让今天的我们处在什么位置？
我们面对的是巨大的文化分裂。一端，人们花越来越多时间待在模拟连接和模拟体验的系统里，逐渐和现实脱节。另一端，人们又被技术压得喘不过气，以至于把手机扔进湖里开始显得像唯一出路。但我想提出一种中间道路：低技术。它意味着使用我们需要的技术，同时仍然有能力退回到自己的生活中。
但这种转变要求我们作为设计师，围绕用户需求来构建技术，而不只是围绕最大利润。当然，盈利永远会是目标，但它不能成为我们唯一优化的目标。因为你的用户不应该被看作一种资源，而应该被看作一种关系。多年来，主导模型一直是提取：做出一个足够有吸引力的东西，让用户无法离开，收割他们的注意力，再把他们被困在产品里的时间变现。
用户给予，产品索取。但关系意味着互惠。为用户创造真实价值，作为回报，他们把信任交给你。而这已经不只是伦理问题。我们正在进入一个时期，科技公司会面临越来越大的压力，必须证明自己产品造成的影响是合理的。
随着监管、公众意识和用户期待不断演化，为用户需求而设计会成为竞争优势。下一代技术中成功的公司，会是那些识别到这种转变，并从现在就开始关注它的公司。但在进入这些经验之前，我想先告诉你们我为什么会做这件事。大家好，我是 Jezebel Desi，一名技术人类学家，也是一名低技术未来主义者。
传统人类学家研究人类和物理环境之间的关系，而我研究人类和技术环境之间的关系。在超过四千小时的田野研究里，我观察人们如何穿行于自己的数字生活，从创业者、CEO 到名人。我不断看到同一件事：人们相信自己不擅长使用技术。他们责怪自己无法专注，责怪自己放不下手机，
也责怪自己被那些本该让生活更轻松的工具压得不知所措。但在 2000 年代初，情况并不是这样。那时界面更容易导航，公司也真的努力教育用户。这主要是因为个人计算还很新，它们必须帮助用户感到自己有能力，采用才会发生。所以我开始问自己：如果技术是为你的神经系统而设计，而不是和它对着干，会是什么样？
如果界面能让你有方向感，而不是让你迷失；如果技术把你送回生活，而不是试图替代生活，会是什么样？所以我和我的联合创始人没有只是停留在理论上，而是在 Lifestyle Lab 里实践它。Lifestyle Lab 是一个产品生态，包括一款电子游戏、教育项目和咨询体验。
如果我们能设计一款帮助人们离开屏幕的游戏，设计真正能转化到现实生活里的项目，以及把用户福祉变成真实产品决策的咨询服务，那我们拥有的就不只是一套理念，而是证明：技术的未来可以既盈利，也对人友好。这就是我来到这里的原因：展示 2000 年代初能教给我们什么，帮助我们构建这个未来所需要的技术。准备好开始了吗？
我必须这么做。欢迎回到 2000 年代初。那是一个更慢、更奇怪、也更有人味的技术时代。这四个经验会教我们理解清晰度、方向感、现实连接，以及服务用户。每一课里，我们都会看一个时代物件，挖掘它带来的经验，再探索今天的应用方式。
第一课。物件是乐高说明书。乐高说明书没有文字，只有全彩、一步一步的插图，清晰到一个还不会阅读的孩子，也能在不需要父母帮忙的情况下照着完成。乐高有一整支团队，会用不同方式把模型搭几十遍，只为找到最清楚的顺序。
当某一步复杂到无法清楚表达时，他们不会增加更多解释，而是简化搭建过程。换句话说，说明书不只是用来教用户，它也是设计师的诊断工具，用来发现体验哪里还需要更清晰。多年下来，乐高还嵌入了更多澄清元素，比如编号袋、零件提示，以及符合逻辑的暂停点，让流程更容易跟上。
所以经验是什么？如果它需要解释，它就需要重新设计。在现代科技产品里，我们常常反过来做：如果需要解释，就堆上工具提示、引导流程，以及有几百篇文章的帮助中心。这些产品假设用户有时间和耐心自己搞懂，而它们的流失率也因此付出代价。
如果你的产品在被使用前需要解释，你就是在要求用户完成本该由设计完成的工作。最强的产品会通过体验本身教学，把引导直接嵌进产品里。谢谢。来看看一些公司怎么应用这一点。No Name 是一个食品杂货品牌，它把清晰度直接嵌进产品视觉身份里，让包装变得极其清楚。
它们不会写“农场新鲜、非浓缩、有机苹果汁”，而是写“苹果饮料”。大多数品牌会叠加营销语言，让顾客先处理一堆信息再做决定，但 No Name 通过直说它是什么来减少困惑。超级马里奥也是这样，它把说明直接嵌进第一关玩法里。
从最早的 1-1 世界到今天最新的游戏，它会引入一个机制，让你尝试，提高难度，然后在此基础上扩展。所以在第一关结束前，玩家已经学会了所有机制，而且没有读过一行说明。
在 Lifestyle Lab，我们通过为界面使用物理空间逻辑来嵌入清晰度。这是一个同住工具，室友可以用它来组织共同生活。但我们没有采用传统软件界面，而是把它设计得像一个物理环境。原因一是互动起来有趣得多，原因二是人类天生就懂得理解物理空间。所以不用在菜单里翻找，家务可以在公告板上找到，留言被放进玻璃罐里，会议发生在懒人沙发上。
好，第二课。物件是加载条。从技术层面看，加载条存在，是因为当年的东西真的需要时间加载。但从心理层面看，加载条还有另一个用途：方向感。方向感会告诉神经系统：你没有迷路，你没有卡住，事情正在发生。加载条只是 2000 年代初众多方向感提示中的一种。
明显的悬停动画会告诉你这个按钮确实可以点击；相机快门声会确认照片已经拍下。每一个这样的提示都回答了四个问题之一：我在哪里？正在发生什么？我能和它互动吗？我的操作成功了吗？当这些问题终于得到回答，你的神经系统就能真正安顿进体验里。
所以经验是什么？迷失感制造依赖，方向感建立信任。当无限滚动、推送通知和算法信息流出现后，我们对方向感的需求增加了。但很多平台反而利用了这种需求，把提示变成黑暗模式，制造紧迫、压力和分心。
因为用户越迷失，就越难抵抗有害循环。因此，作为设计师，我们有责任创造支持人类行为的环境，而不是剥削它。仅仅设计一个“不剥削”的东西还不够。我们必须主动设计能帮助用户调节神经系统的体验，去抵消他们现实中已经承受的其他压力。
否则，我们可能会失去用户，不是因为产品不好，而是因为他们的神经系统在来到这里之前就已经超载了。来看看公司怎么应用这一点。Shazam 会通过让产品每个状态都非常明显来给用户方向感。用户可能正在派对上，一边聊天，一边想在歌结束前识别它。所以 Shazam 迅速让他们有方向，给出答案，然后让开位置。它是一个巨大的按钮，一个聆听状态，
一个搜索状态，然后是非常明显的确认状态。宜家则通过把整家店变成一张巨大地图来给用户方向感。箭头很大，房间标签很明显，路线直接画在地上。这很聪明，因为除此之外，你要怎么抵消在一个巨大仓库里、周六下午拥挤又紧张地导航带来的压倒感？在 Lifestyle Lab，我们在网站上通过非常明显的悬停状态给用户方向感。
每当我们设计像这次这样的演示时，我们不用标准的顺序幻灯片导航，而是设计一种菜单式导航，让你能提前预览整个体验，这样你始终知道自己处在哪里。我们也用光标来减少章节切换时的迷失感。它会引导你的视线穿过过渡，让你知道接下来该看哪里。最后，我们通过设计一个非常明确的收束时刻来表示一课完成。
就像这样。好，第三课。物件是宝可梦。
在 2000 年代初，出现了一批把数字体验延伸到现实世界的产品，比如宝可梦。它从 Game Boy 上的东西开始，延伸成一个包含集换式卡牌、玩具、手册和比赛的完整生态。通过创造让人们在现实中连接的理由，这个品牌被编织进人们的日常生活。它不只是构建了一个人们可以玩的产品，而是构建了一个人们可以参与的世界。所以经验是什么？
技术应该激活现实，而不是替代现实。
今天大多数产品，都是用数字近似物取代现实行为。我们消费社区，而不是参与社区；观看体验，而不是亲身体验；展示身份，而不是发展身份。但技术应该成为桥梁，帮助人们更深入地参与现实，鼓励屏幕之外的行动。
来看公司怎么应用这一点。Strava 为跑者和骑行者做到了这一点。它的应用不只是记录运动，而是把物理世界变成社交界面，鼓励用户穿行于自己的城市。人们甚至开始创作 Strava 艺术，通过完成路线，在地图上画出巨大的图形。当技术给人们机会和现实互动时，这些奇妙的人类行为就会发生。
Tinder 也是一个有趣例子。大多数约会应用把用户困在一种令人疲惫的循环里：滑动、匹配、聊天、消失、再出现。但 Tinder 针对滑动疲劳做出了回应。今年三月，它一边大力宣布 AI 匹配功能，一边也宣布了线下活动。这说明了一件事：即使 Tinder 也意识到，更好的数字匹配还不够。
真正的产品问题，是如何完成从可能性到现实的交接。因为应用可以创造连接的感觉，但活动能创造真实连接发生的实际条件。下面是我们在 Lifestyle Lab 如何激活现实。在游戏里，玩家搬到一个有意识生活的社区，在那里建立关系、处理日常生活，并参与小镇文化。
但这个游戏不只是模拟更好的生活方式，它会把这些方式转化到现实生活。其中一个游戏机制是共同居住，玩家会和室友住在一起。等一下，我带你们去看看。好，我们到了。玩家学习如何共享空间、协调家务、表达需求，并建立让家庭顺畅运转的系统。但学习不会只停留在游戏里。
玩家会解锁这个系统的现实版本，用在自己真正的室友关系中。所以当他们的游戏角色升级时，他们在现实生活中也会升级。第四课。物件是《动物森友会》。
《动物森友会》被设计成镜像真实生活的节奏。它使用主机内部时钟，所以如果你的生活里是早晨，游戏里也是早晨；如果外面是冬天，你的小镇也是冬天。商店会关门，角色会睡觉，这意味着有些时候就是没那么多事情可做。这些限制创造了自然的停止点，让玩家可以离开。任天堂能够这样设计，是因为它的商业模式不是基于参与度变现。你买下游戏时，它已经收到钱了。
所以它不需要为留存而设计，而可以为期待感而设计。经验是什么？如果它需要注意力，参与度就会开始驱动产品。今天大多数科技产品都带着一种焦虑型依恋风格，总是害怕你离开，用恐惧策略和操控把你困住。但健康的技术应该是安全型依恋风格，相信用户会因为你创造的价值而回来。
挑战在于，即使设计师想构建更健康的体验，商业模式也经常把他们拉向相反方向。但当你的商业成功和用户成功绑定在一起，设计就能开始朝同一个方向移动。来看公司怎么应用这一点。Pinterest 最近发起了一场活动，口号是：你能在网上找到的最好的东西，是一个让你下线的理由。
对一家科技公司来说，这是相当激进的表达，尤其是它的商业模式基于广告收入。它怎么能一边告诉用户下线，一边保持商业成功？Pinterest 的答案是缩短灵感和行动之间的距离。因为如果不加控制，灵感本身会变成一种娱乐形式：无尽收藏从未做过的食谱，和从未开始的项目。一个后院灵感板的价值，不在于它被收藏了。
它的价值在于，有人买了串灯，摆好了桌子，邀请朋友过来。但 Pinterest 不需要让用户永远在线，才能保持商业成功。如果它能帮助人更快找到正确想法，更顺畅地买到所需物品，并把更多时间花在真正生活这个想法上，而不是不断搜索它，那双方都会赢。
Time Left 会组织陌生人之间的精选晚餐，但它不卖一次性门票，而是转向订阅模式。这不只是定价模型，它让公司的商业成功和用户成功对齐。因为 Time Left 通过持续订阅赚更多钱，而人们也会在持续出现时建立更好的连接。所以同样，双方都赢。他们还进一步通过围绕社交连接的品牌合作，让收入来源更多元。
这很重要，因为这意味着业务可以通过创造更多现实连接机会来增长，而不只是向用户收更多钱。在 Lifestyle Lab，我们面临的挑战是：如何让游戏对目标用户保持可及，同时又不建立一个依赖于把他们困在游戏里的商业模式？因为我们的目标是帮助玩家练习可以在游戏外使用的技能。所以围绕游戏内停留时间来设计商业模式，会和我们的目标相冲突。
因此，我们没有问：如何从用户身上变现？我们问的是：当用户学会这些技能时，还有谁会受益？学校会受益，因为学生更好地为未来做好准备；工作场所会受益，因为团队更有组织；社区会受益，因为成员拥有更多实际工具，可以生活、沟通并互相支持。
所以我们没有让用户承担成本，而是围绕那些从用户成长中受益的机构来建立模型。这样，我们的收入就不必来自提取用户，而是来自用户变得更有能力时创造出的价值。因为事情就是这样：商业模式决定产品可以自由成为什么。如果公司的成功依赖于用户变得更有能力，那么服务用户就会成为公司生存的方式。
在这四课里，我们学到要嵌入清晰度，提供方向感，激活现实，并服务用户。作为设计师，我们有责任创造共同现实的条件。这个房间里的每一个产品，都会塑造人们如何花时间。
塑造他们如何穿行世界，如何连接彼此，也如何连接自己。所以如果我们想构建一个用户被照顾的现实，就必须把这些原则整合进构建方式里。因为下一代技术中成功的公司，不会是那些拼命争抢最多注意力的公司，而会是那些赢得用户回归的公司。谢谢。